you know the past few weeks got me
thinking I've been doing top 10 list for
a while and the past month had me
looking at the top 10 of many things in
the year in the decade so I wondered how
about something a bit different perhaps
it's time to put out something a bit
more personal for you
I've been busy coming up with these
lists and I think it's high time I came
up with something more candid and
personalised to share with you after all
being in the anime community for so many
years has made me realize that the
community is one that grows through
people getting closer and knowing each
other better
well I've shared some of my opinions
through those top 10 lists I think the
lists are constrained with some criteria
following the tradition of people making
their top anime lists as we enter a new
decade this time I present to you my top
10 favourite anime from this past decade
yep no hard categories no criteria no
qualifications just an open sharing of
the shows that have either impressed me
touched my heart or open my eyes to new
horizons for the past few years
[Music]
where do I start with mob psycho at the
midpoint of the decade one punch man was
the hottest thing in town featuring an
excellent mix of superhero action and
comedy it was great but it's one's other
title mob psycho 100 that really caught
my eye but this point everyone already
knows about the famed animation of the
mob psycho anime but it's hardly the
main reason I put it on my personal
favorites list in addition to the
renowned animation
I think mob psycho is a show with a
great mixture of comedy and substance
it's relatable and I can resonate with
the protagonists growth as the story
goes on looking at the main character
mob we've all been in this situation
right yep just - the superpowers
transformations and the things that
spice up anime as a whole but that's the
beauty of anime and fantasy now isn't it
[Applause]
the theme of relatable life crossing
paths with fantasy and destiny continues
with my next pick your name this decade
scene anime breaking into the mainstream
and a large part of it is due to anime
movies and I don't mean tie-in movies to
popular shows since we probably have a
billion one piece in a root or Pokemon
movies already a good part of the decade
has been marked by the release of
blockbusters by famed directors in your
name is at the forefront years ago your
name kicked off a revolution and took
the world by storm
all of a sudden anime movies were
mainstream and people even those who've
not watched anime before took notice of
this medium that boldly stood beside the
Giants and blockbusters of Hollywood and
why not
if the statement anime is art was given
a material form your name would be it
your name is makoto zheng kai's best
work in my opinion it intertwines
reality and fantasy very very well it
isn't groundbreaking in terms of writing
but visually it's one of the prettiest
anime films out there the stories
narrative does an excellent job of
connecting us the audience to its
endearing characters for many your names
their gateway to the world of anime
movies in makoto shinkai and it's as
good of a gateway as you can get
[Music]
or at all miss me
Tom oh that's new
for everything I just said about your
name it's not even my favorite anime
movie from the past decade actually that
title goes to the key or any production
a silent voice for me this movies easily
my favorite in recent memory because of
how close to home its themes up there's
a great drama and an even greater
redemption story that revolves around
what we see in life regularly I mean how
often do you see anime dive headfirst
into bullying and its many forms as well
as a young boys struggle of redemption
that's not even getting to the more
mechanical aspects of the movie such as
the beautiful art of visuals the film
isn't afraid to make you feel emotions a
lot of other movies and stories are too
afraid to touch I hope you find the time
to experience this one for yourself
[Music]
you know what isn't aesthetically
pleasing people being eaten by fellow
humans with the capability to transform
into alien monstrosity x' parasites
actually the adaptation of quite an old
series before the wave of old-school
adaptations that included Dora row and
BEM there was parasite arguably one of
the thematically strongest anime in its
time masterfully weaving together the
concept of body horror an environmental
message and high-octane action makes
parasite a true winner in my eyes of
course many people back then probably
remember parasite for its dubstep
soundtrack but overall I'd say it's an
exciting anime that holds up to the new
decade it may not be as culturally
significant as some of its brethren in
2014 but this is an action horror anime
that I wouldn't want you to miss the
story of the growing bond between
Shinichi and Mickey is something that
will always stay with me in the years to
come
[Music]
[Applause]
speaking of tooth clenched teamwork let
me introduce you to the next anime
inline Vinland saga a story about
Vikings fueled by a boy's quest for
revenge there are many ways Vinland saga
could have sputtered and become an
afterthought after a few episodes the
hype was there and as they say the
higher you are the harder you fall
thankfully in Finland sagas delivered
since its first episode personally my
favorite part of the series has to be
the character dynamics past that and
also like to direct everyone's attention
to its storytelling as I said before
it's a graphic story of war that pulls
no punches in presenting the
catastrophic realities of such an event
it helps that it's also got some
historical elements so you history buffs
here's an anime for you it's too bad
that so many are sleeping on Finland
saga it may not have blown up like Demon
Slayer but I firmly believe that it had
all the makings of an anime epic that
could very well be the best show of 2019
as a last note a skill adds easily one
of my top three characters of 2019
[Music]
[Music]
if you prefer something more casual and
closer to our neighborhood starring a
blonde hothead perhaps this next pick
will be more to your liking rarely do
you see anime that go all the way in
presenting different perspectives of a
topic I like the different point of view
storytelling in the anime as for me it's
one of the key points that makes it
unique Quentin Tarantino's my favorite
Hollywood director and I feel like his
style of storytelling can be seen in Rio
gonna Rita's work despite being
disappointed by its ending Durarara
still holds a place in my heart I love
everything about it in particular I
think it shines in how it delivers its
character arcs pretty much everyone
relevant is interesting and I liked how
the characters were written and
developed as the series goes on corners
Odin or Giovanna you are you may God at
least the characters in Durarara are
still easy to keep track of unlike the
ones in the anthology series JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure
[Music]
[Music]
it's certainly one of the things that
would prove daunting to uninitiated
people trying to get into Jojo the long
narrative and amount of characters might
be daunting and if they aren't perhaps
the over-the-top bizarreness of the
series could deter people from trying it
out that's a crying shame really because
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure all of those
long seasons of it is for me one of the
most entertaining chronicles out there
not to say that the plot and characters
lack depth but if I were to talk Jojo
and put entertainment right at the top
the series and characters are so
over-the-top and creative you've got a
wonder how they keep getting ideas for
this from creative references to visual
techniques
Jojo is truly a work of art the memes
speak for themselves
newbies might be deterred from catching
up to the series but its huge fanbase is
more than enough to give it one hell of
a staying power trust me okay you won't
be hearing the last of Jojo references
anytime soon it may be ending but at
least it's formally made its mark on
anime history I was there when it first
aired and it instantly broke anime into
the mainstream thanks to its gritty tone
cynical atmosphere and lack of things
that typically deter Norma viewers from
anime attack on Titan put anime on the
map remember the demon slayer fever a
few months back that was attack on Titan
in 2013 I'm telling you there Serge was
even bigger
I think attack on Titan simply got
better and better as it went on from a
suspenseful story of human survival and
standing up against all odds it evolved
and explored new frontiers so for me
part 2 of season 3 is the best sequel
anime of 2019 and the manga is also
currently at its peak - with the
decisive battle against the major Titans
now behind us we await what's to come as
the series marches towards a triumphant
conclusion this year
in contrast IOT and its anticipated
ending the next anime my second favor of
the decade works with a foregone
conclusion I'm talking about get auto
bujji's magnum opus during his peak
years in the early part of the decade
fate/zero
being given the reins to write the
prequel to the ever-popular fate/stay
night the aura butcher did it the only
way he can with a dark gripping story
that's thematically great with awesome
characters resulting in the best entry
in the faith series for me that's not
even mentioning the more ambiguity that
people have praised the series for the
writing is stellar and the action is on
another level for an early 2010 show it
also gave us Archer Gilgamesh in his
full glory one of the best villains in
fate the endings are a butcher trademark
in his mastery of writing tragedy we
knew that the ending was a foregone
conclusion given how faith state night
turned out but it still hurt when I
first saw it 2017 may be the year of
fate but before grand order took the
world by storm before you throw tables
ubw and before heaven's feel fate/zero
already set the tone and benchmark for
the fate series going forward things are
looking up for tight moons cash cow
franchise and I personally believe that
fate/zero success at the start of the
decade definitely had something to do
with it
here we are one final slot to go I'd
like to introduce you to my favorite
anime this decade it goes to the show
that's not even originally from this
decade I'm talking about the 2011 remake
of hunter hunter where do I start with
hunter hunter for one it's a guy she's a
true genius when it comes to
characterization and character
development I'll say this
Hunter hunter has my favorite villain
fight and shown in arc it's an amazing
series that trumps all other anime for
me when have you ever seen an anime
maintain its quality throughout the
years even with its numerous genre
shifts it starts simple but the
escalation of stakes and scale is on
point everything comes to a pinnacle in
the Chimaera and arc the greatest arc is
shown in anime with its characters and
plot development all this talk about
writing could have undermined the 2011
versions visuals and sound even those
are spot-on
the visuals are crisp and amazing and
it's a key reason that the 2011 version
is as good as it is now if only to gosh
II would hurry up and get back to the
manga consistently his works too awesome
to not be finished in our lifetime with
that I conclude my list for me these 10
anime have gone beyond everything else
to claim their spot as my favorite
animes of the decade I want to know your
personal list and see if there are any
shows that we share so make sure to
leave your comments and tell me which
anime are your favorite from the past
decade who knows you might meet a new
friend on the comments section while
you're at it
wishing you a happy 2020 til next time
[Music]